اي تهديد على اسرائيل بعد
اليوم لن ننسى الضائع التي حصلت في السابع
من اكتوبر لن ننسى المجزره ولا الاغتصاب
ولا القتل ولا التعذيب ولن ننسى اختطاف
مواطنينا حتى الان اعدنا 100 وع
مختطفين ونحن ملتزمون بان نعيدهم جميعا
الى
بيوتهم نحن هذا ما يشغلنا وهذا ما نعمل
عليه على مدار الساعه ويشمل الان ايضا لن
ا ابدا عما فعلته ما فعله وحوش حماس
لابنائنا وبناتنا ولذلك لا بديل عن النصر
الساحق علينا ان ننتصر
وسوف ننتصر
مواطن اسرائيل اليوم هو يوم
الذك المحرقه
العالم ولا كفه اكثر ولا منطق بالامس ليله
الكارثه
يتهموننا
بالاتهام الكاذب باباده
الشعب
اسس النازيون الجدد الذين جاءوا يقتلون
شعبنا هذا كتاب هتلر كفاحي بالعربي هذا
الكتاب وجده محاربون في بيوت مواطنين في
قطاع غز
وجدوه وهو ضد اللا
سميه على هذا يربون اولادهم وعليه انا
مصمم ان اقضي على حماس وان لا يكون في
اليوم بعد ذلك ان يكون جه تربي على
الارهاب وتدعو الى القضاء على اسرائيل
والقضاء على الشعب اليهودي
جميعا النازيون الجدد
هؤلاء وتوجههم عن طريق جنوب افريقيا الى
الى
ايضا بسبب الاستعداد في لهاي ايضا من ان
لا
يبعدوه الكثيرون في العالم لم يعرفوا شيئا
او لم يتعلموا شيئا من الكارثه ونحن لكننا
درسنا وفهمنا واستوعب الدرس الاساسي
للكارثه اننا ندافع عن نفسنا
بانفسنا ولا احد يستطيع ان يقوم ويمكن ان
يقوم بذلك مكاننا ايضا علينا ان نكون
اقوياء وان نكون مصممين وان نرد الحرب لمن
يريد قتلنا
ودوله الشعب اليهودي قامت
من من الكارثه وللدفاع عن الشعب اليهودي
واسرائيل كما كل دوله مستقله لديها الحق
الاساسي في الدفاع عن نفسها لا احد يستطيع
ان ياخذ منا هذا الحق لا احد يستطيع ان
يوقفنا ان نصمم على ذلك نحن نحارب حربا
صادقه
وايضا حرب اخلاقيه وهذه الحرب فرضت علينا
على يد عدو وحشي الذي يعلن انه يريد ان
يقتل كل اليهود في السابع من اكتوبر قتلوا
وذبحوا واغتصبوا وقتلوا
اطفالا كانوا كذا كان بم كان نا جميعا و
محربو حماس هؤلاء النازيون الجدد
ال المذبح القادمه هي مساله وقت مع
هؤلاء ان يجب علينا القضاء على حماس حتى
لو كان ياخذ وقتا لن نتوقف سنواصل هذه
المهمه
وايضا ابطالنا في الحرب القيادات
والجنود الاسبوع محاربون
وقتلوا مئات المخربين في خانيونس وايضا
دمروا فوق الارض وتحت الارض ويحاربون
بطوليه
الهيه ومن اجل حياتنا في بلادنا ومن اجل
ذلك ومن اجل ان نضمن ذلك لاجيال قادمه
وايضا وجهت وزير الدفاع وان يكون لديهم
امام الحكومه برنامج برنامج في مجال
الصناعات العسكريه لسنوات قادمه نحن نقوم
كذلك بميزانيات كبيره وسنقوم بذلك من اجل
ان يكون لدينا استقلاليه
امنيه الشعب يؤمن بمحاربي ويؤمن بروحه
بروحه
ويؤمن يا هؤلاء ونحن جميعا فخور بهم
ونحتضن
واريد ان اقول شيء
ما لاسف هناك في داخلنا ان يختاروا ويشكوا
في تصميمنا وقدرتنا للانتصار
وايضا وايضا هؤلاء الذين يزرعون
الشكه اريد ان اقول لكم مواطن اسرائيل هذه
الاصوات هي اصوات قليله
وخاطئه ويخطئون ايضا وسننتصر انتصارا حاسم
وايضا التزامنا ان ننتصر انتصار حاسم وهي
الضمانه الاساسيه وايضا
ليس لدينا امكانيه اخرى بسوى الانتصار
الحاسم نحن سننتصر لاننا لدينا شعب قوي
والمحاربون الاقوياء الذين يضحون بانفسهم
من اجل ان اسرائيل ومن اجل ان ديزل كما
قال ايضا في وصيته و بوصيته
انهي وايضا على انني اصبت وكانت لدي
الخيار ان اكون في
في الوراء ولكن لم اسف ان اكون محاربا
وبالعكس هي هو قرار الافضل والذي
اتخذته لان ابناء الشعب وهذا الشعب
المحاربون والقاده والمحاربون ومعا نحارب
وباذن الله معا ننتصر
شكرا
الاسئله
النا
الزراء وايضا رئيس الشباك في القيام بلجنه
تحقيق حكوميه وايضا لماذا لا نقيم هذه
اللجنه وان تريد ان تستغل هذه المنصه بان
ايضا تقول ان تقول قولا بهذا الشان قلت
رايي و وفيما يتعلق
بالتحقيقات س يجب ان تكون في نهايه ولا لم
اغير رايي ولا اتحدث عن القاضه وايضا
السياسيين من يعالجوا هذه الامور وان
يبحثوا عن امور اخرى وان ان يعملوا على
الانتصار في الحرب هناك وقت سيكون لهذه
الاشياء لاحقا واريد ان اقول لكم امرا اخر
الحكومه هي التي تقرر
في المجال في الوقت المناسب وايضا فيما
يتعلق بعضو ال
ايضا مكتبي دان هذه الامور وهي امور لا
يجب ان تقال وايضا هذا الامر غير مناسب
وايضا الكثير من الامور السقيفه التي تقول
والتي تقال واسفي وايضا بخلاف ما اتخذه
ورايي
انا هناك امور مسؤوليه عديمه
المسؤوليه 13 اريد ان اقول هذا الامر ليس
امر
سخيف وايضا فيما يتعلق ببليس انه كان هناك
حديث مع السنوار ان هناك مؤامره
معه وايضا هذه سيدي رئيس
الوزراء هذا السؤال ليس
لك ايضا ارجو ان
تحدد ما صرحت فيما يتعلق ما صرحت بهتل
البرنامج خطتك الخاصه بك كيف تهاجم
الحكومه انا احارب بحماس وانتم
تحاربني انا لا اوافق
معك رئيس مصر قال هو غير جاهز لان يتحدث
معك هاتفيا وايضا فيما يتعلق بقطر هجمت
قطر وايضا هذه الامور التي
نشرت هذه الامور حساسه وفيما يتعلق ب مصير
المخطوفين
شك شكرا على هذا
الصياغه لا لا
العلاقات الميكروفونات ليست في
مكانها العلاقات مع مصر تدار
بشكل جيد وبين الحكومات كل الوقت هناك
بطبيعه الحال واحد كل منا لديه المصالح
لمصر لديها الامور التي تركز عليها وانا
هم يقلقون لمصالحهم ونحن نقلق لمصالحنا
وفيما يتعلق بقطر انا لا اتراجع عن اي
كلمه قلتها انا ان اتنازل عن مسار واحد من
الضغط على حماس ومن يستطيع ان يضغط على
حماس من اجل اعاده مخطوفين
قطر تضم
وتستضيف حماس وايضا يمكنها ان تضغط على
حماس والتزمت ان تؤكد لنا الوصول الادويه
وايضا للمخطوفين وايضا قالت
انه ايضا جاءت وقالت انها يمكن ان تقوم
بذلك وايضا هي كوسيط يجب ان تؤكد وتضمن
ذلك وايضا
ان نتحدث بهذا
الش سيدي رئيس الوزراء
هل موضوع حكومه الدمقراطيه في غزه بدون
السنوار هل هي رد على
مطالبك لا لا نحن سنقضي على قياده حماس
كما التزمنا وفي اليوم بعد حماس لن يكون
هناك هذا النظام ولن تكون لديه القدرات
العسكريه
والمدنيه سيتم تدميرها وايضا كما قلت كما
هو واضح لكم انه يجب ان يكون هناك جهه
اخرى ايضا اداره
تكنوقراطيه وايضا هذه هذه الجهه لا يجب ان
تكون تربي للارهاب وايضا لا يكون لدي هذا
الكتاب وهكذا نعمل
وكما فيما يتعلق بالقضاء الحماس فهو
قائم سيدي رئيس الوزراء هناك غدا في مباني
الامه سيكون هناك اجتماع للعوده الى قطاع
غزه انت تحدثت في الماضي ضد هذا
الكره هل هناك تغير في موقفك سياستنا فيما
يتعلق باليوم ما بعد سيتم تحديده بالمجلس
الوزراء الموسع وكل شيء اخر وايضا وزراء
واعضاء كنيست لديهم اراء مختلفه وايضا هذا
لا يلزم حكومه اسرائيل ما يلزم حكومه
اسرائيل هي القرارات الت تتخذ من قبل مجلس
الوزراء وكما بطبيعه الحال سيتم نشرها لم
اي قرار بهذا الشان هذا حتى
الانس
الوزراء الجمهور يدفع ثمن كبير لهذا الحرب
وفيما يتعلق بتجنيد الاحتياط وايضا 100
يوم انا شخصيا كنت في التجنيد
الاحتيا وايضا حكومه في
رئاستك ايضا هناك تمويل المنظمات
التي كما طلبت الاحزاب المتدينه ايضا هناك
سؤال ممنهج وهو ليس عادل
و رؤساء
المعارضه
قالوا هل انت تنادي على
المتدينين
هنا لا نكون سخيفين هناك لدينا تركيب
ائتلافي ويعبر عن الجمهور ما
رايت رايت متدينين
الذين يساعدون
في
الرض
وايضا يقومون بجمع الجثث واجزاء الجثث
ويساعدون بكل طريقه وايضا يساعدون جيش
الدفاع لا يمكن ان اتجاهل ذلك وانت لا
يمكن ان تعلن احد الامور الكبيره التي
كانت هنا وايضا
نجحنا ان نكون لدينا هناك موافقه
وطنيه ويمكن ان اقول لك هناك امور اخرى
هناك ايضا نمول
الامور ما يقولون عن دوله اسرائيل هذه
مموله ايضا هذه الامور
تفك
مره اخرى هناك تقسيم للاعمال وانا اركز
على القضاء على حماس وانتم تقومون بالحرب
ضدي ما رايك ان يكون هناك في المظاهرات في
كيرم شالوم لمنع دخول الشاحنات وايضا ههم
يدعون الى وقف ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه
قلت اكثر من مره بدون المساعدات الانسانيه
الاساس وهما نقدمه لا يمكن ان ننجز
المهمه لا يمكن ان ننهي الحرب بتحقيق
اهدافها وعليه نحن نعطي هذه المساعدات
وانا امن افهم هذه العائلات وايضا هي هي
امور طبيعيه ولكن هذه ليست سياستنا
ونحن وجهنا ونا وجهات ان نعالج هذا الامر
لدينا ان ان نركز على الهدف الحربي وان
نعطي المساعدات الانسانيه الاساس
رئيس الوزراء هناك في
عائلات المخطوفين تتظاهر في ك ساريا امام
منزلك حسب ما يقولون انه لم يسمح لهم ان
يتوقفوا هناك ويتظاهر هناك 300 متر من
البيت هل هي توجيه من جانبك او من من
حولك هل انت تنوي ان تظهر وتتحدث معهم في
احد
السبوت من حقهم التظاهر وان لا نعطي
توجيهات الجهات الامنيه هي التي قررت وانا
لا اتدخل في هذه القرارات الامر الثاني
انا تحدثت واستمعت معهم كل الوقت
وايضا اسفي هناك بعض من سجل ما كان وايضا
اريد ان اقول لكم
اخر لا يستطيع احد ان
يوجهني انا اصبت في محاوله لل تخليص
مخطوفين في طائره سبنا يا جندي قمت بذلك
واخي سقط في هذه المهمه في عنتيبي
لتحرير المخطوفين في انتيبي في
اوغندا لا احد يقول لي ما اقوم انا اعمل
بذلك كل
الوقت هذا لا يساعد واريد ان اقول ان
بصراحه انا لا استطيع ان اسيطر على
المشاعر ومن ينظمون
هذه المظاهرات وهذا لا يساعد نحن نحن
بحاجه الى دفعه انا اقول بذلك
بمسؤوليه فقط
هو يجب ان ندعم الضغط على حماس والهدف
الاساس هو اعاده
مخطوفين مبارك تحدثت عن احتلال خانيونس ما
هي بعد خانيونس
التوجه جنوبا هدفنا هو القضاء على سلطه
حماس
وايضا لا يمكن ان نسمح انفاسنا ان توجد
هناك قوات محاربه منظمه في داخل قطاع غزه
وايضا فيما يتعلق بخطط مواصله الحرب لا
يمكن ان نشرحها هنا نوضحها هنا امر واحد
انه ان لا يمكن انتهي الحرب الحرب ستنتهي
قالوا انها بمنتصف هذا الشهر وهذا ما لم
يحدث حتى لا نكمل المهمه
ستمر الذي خطف في
غزه انه قتل بسبب غازات
سامه هل جيش الدفاع ينشر غازات سامه في
عملياتها
و ايضا
لماذا اوضحت بادخال 150 شاحنه من القم الى
قطاع غزه فيما يتعلق بالسؤال الاول انا لا
اوضح ما جيش الدفاع يقوم هذه امور تتعلق
باسرار الحرب نقوم بكل ما هو يمكن ان نضر
بال المخطوفين فيما يتعلق اينه موجودين
ولذلك نغير خطط الحرب فيما يتعلق
بال في الشاحنات انا لم اقرر ان ادخال
القمح لنصف عام هذا امر غير صحيح هناك
هناك قمح لنصف سنه ارسل
لغزه تم
اقرار عدد من الشاحنات التي تدخل الى غزه
فيما يتعلق بالمساعدات الانسانيه التي
ندخلها الامر الاخر بخلاف ماقيل ليس فقط
اتفقنا على ذلك بشكل مطلق في مجلس الحرب
وايضا اوضحته او عرضت ذلك على مجلس
الوزراء وهناك امثله اخرى ان بالاخبار
الكاذبه
وانا احاول في المؤتمرات الصحفيه
بشكل ان اوضح هذه الامور ان هذه اخبار
كاذبه فيما يتعلق بامور الحرب وكما ما
قررته وما لم اقرر وايضا اوضت هنا بعض
الامور سؤال
اخير هل رئيس الوزراء هل انت قب املك من
قرار محكمه الهاي فيما يتعلق بالطرق
لحماس ما
انت تعتقد حول ذلك اعتقد ان هذا امر يخيب
الامال
و لم يتم هناك اتخاذ قرار بوقف القر هذا
امر صحيح ولكن
نحن نحن
نقرر
ونعمل بما يتعلق ملائم لامنها ونقرر في
الايام القادمه حول الخطوات القادمه شكرا
لكم شكرا لكم جميعا